hier en fin d'émission en recevant
plateau et méline une ancienne candidate
des 12 coups de midi pour évoquer l
affaire christian quesada et raymond
notre chroniqueur qui devait être là et
qui va arriver dans un instant avait
tenu des propos qui avait beaucoup fait
réagir autour de la table ici tous les
avis sont les bienvenus et même quand on
n'est pas d'accord il faut dire les
choses il faut donner son avis c'est ce
qui fait la force de cette émission
et c'est pareil dans balances ton post
alors raymond avait tenu donc des propos
qui avait beaucoup fait réagir de
nombreux chroniqueurs ont été choqués
dont gilles verdez qui est toujours
voilà qui est gilles verdez exubérant
comme on les aime
mais voilà il s'en est pris à raymond
voillat même hors antenne voilà vous
étiez tous les deux vous ayez un petit
peu à peu tirés et la dispute a été
assez virulente
alors gilles et raymond montils se
rabibocher ce soir on vous dit tout mais
juste avant un petit rappel des faits
regarde hier soir sur le plateau de thé
pmp étaient invités emeline une jeune
femme qui en 2016 avait participé à
l'émission les 12 coups de midi de tf1
et qui avait croisé la route de
christian quesada la jeune femme révélée
avoir entretenu une correspondance via
des messages privés sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le champion du jeu télé
jusqu'au jour où il lui aurait envoyé
des photos de son sexe sans
sollicitation préalable une présence en
plateau qui a soulevé l'admiration de
certains chroniqueurs mais qui n'a pas
fait l'unanimité
à l'image de raymond qui sont épris de
la jeune femme moi je t'en veux un tout
petit peu ne pas l'avoir bloqué et ne
plus parler à jamais là on veut là alors
dénoncé parce que tout à l'heure tu
arrives tu dis je je réfléchis pas à
porter plainte pourquoi porter plainte
maintenant fallait porter plainte
les matches et que j'aime beaucoup mais
tu dis n'importe quoi si la séquence a
été soutenu par certains téléspectateurs
d'autres ont été choqués par cette
sortie je peux tu dire qu'on n'a pas de
chance tout comme gilles verdez en
coulisses la dispute s'est prolongée les
deux hommes se sont expliqués de façon
très virulente mais alors que s'est-il
réellement passé
raymond et gilles sont-ils
réconciliables on vous
tout ce soir alors c'est vrai que nous
voilà on est une grande famille est ici
dans l'émission et quand il ya deux
chroniqueurs qui s'embrouillent un peu
on n'aime pas ça vous dit et tout ça
même géré accueillir appui géraldine
dirait que vous étiez voilà vous avoue
que ça fait de la peine
normalement oui parce que ça se passe
ici mais après ça se passe pas derrière
dans sa salle dans les coulisses jusque
dans les coulisses ensuite voilà
benjamin mois ils se sont un peu
engueulé tous les deux moi j'ai arrêté
j'arrête l'histoire j'ai essayé en tous
les cas merci en tout cas merci tour
d'autres qu'aux témoignages
alors raymond est derrière le rideau a
quelque chose à dire à gilles raymond ce
que tu m'entends je vous entends un bon
soir est bon dans soir les amis alors
mon raymond tu es mon pote tu le sais on
se connaît depuis des années à la basse
était chauffeur livreur je le dit et il
est vraiment et continuer de
chauffeur-livreur vraiment tout savoir
qu'il se réveille très très tôt tous les
matins matinée ils se réveillent à
quelle heure tu travailles mon chéri
4h45 4h45 simagrées et le soir il vient
rejoindre ses potes ici je sais que tu
vis une aventure exceptionnelle avec
nous c'est magique depuis qu'on se
connaît on a fait plein de choses
ensemble parce qu'on est à la radio
ensemble et on n'a fait que des dark ah
ouais tu sais que tu es mon pote avant
tout et c'est vrai qu'il y ait revoilà
il ya eu d une séquence comme on les
aime pas dans l'émission et même après
dans les couloirs parce qu'on peut tout
se dire
mais voilà on n'aime pas qu'on voit là
çà çà çà çà çà va trop loin surtout
voilà c'est surtout après position
progrès mais après après on se rabiboche
sont alors ça autre chose mon raymond je
sais que c'est qu'un petit peu chaud
entre gilles et toi en coulisse hier
j'étais encore là et quand je suis monté
on m'a dit il ya eu des échauffourées
est-ce que tu as quelque chose à dire à
jill aujourd'hui et gilles tu nous diras
si tu acceptes ce qu'il advient moi moi
je vais juste dire une chose je vais
dire que hier c'est vrai que sur la
séquence des mines je démarre ma phrase
en disant c'est pas bien ce que tu as
fait tu m'as tu vois ça c'est le début
de la séquence sur emmeline j'ai pas
aimé je n'aurais pas dû dire ça comme ça
j'aurais pas dû commencer ma séquence
comme ça après sur gil j c'est un grand
garçon il a son caractère tpm pc une
famille moi j'ai mon caractère aussi on
se dit des mots on se parle et iard
benjamin était là le ton est monté
peut-être la fatigue peut être plein de
trucs moi personnellement j'ai rien à
dire à j-6 gilles il a quelque chose à
me dire qu'ils me le disent moi j'ai
rien à dire à gilles personnellement tp
un pc une famille ça reste une famille
dans toutes les familles il ya des
engueulades entre les frères et soeurs
ça existe ça arrive mais parler comme
des bonhommes maintenant 6 kg il a
quelque chose à me dire qu'ils me le
disent
benjamin il était là il était témoin il
a tout vu tout entendu moi j'ai rien à
dire à gilles régis corriger les scouts
à qui je veux dire à m
j'ai rien à dire à raymond vous
l'existoire et mon nom mais ça va parce
qu'il dit parce que franchement
j'essaye de faire des limons et j'en ai
pas du tout envie c'était quand même une
agression c'est à dire qu'il ya eu et a
eu des menaces il ya eu de la violence
et les injures mais non mais non mais il
faut remettre ça dans le conte exposé
était là je voulais séparer on est que
le ton est monté c'est vrai que ça a
décollé d'un côté d'autres c'est vrai
que tu as ta pas volu arrêté j voudrais
te mets ta ta ta ta robe et du charbon
dans la machine à chaque fois vraiment
aussi de monter dans les tours
bon voilà après après si vous êtes vous
parler on va pouvoir voir mais moi je
vous le dit ça m'est arrivé sur ce
plateau de m'engueuler que des gens on
s'est engueulés hors plateau après on
s'est embrassés pour pas rester comme ça
pour une sombre histoire parce que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord
franchement après je vais pas passer
outre ce serait bien dommage mémoire
tous les cas je pense que lyon pour
l'emploi là et vous restez calmes
opposition les deux mois je pense que à
minima à minima je pense que raymond
pourrais je dis pas de vrai parce qu'il
fait ce qu'il veut me faire des excuses
je pense à minima vu la situation d'hier
et tout ce qui s'est passé
voilà c'est quoi on va le laisser
vraiment séduit je peux répondre tout de
suite peut répondre tout à fait laisser
la nuit pour réfléchir non je te réponds
du tofu et on a on a entendu qu'après
ouais mais c'est dommage de dire des
insultes alors que c'est lui qui insulte
un message à sandra les gens n'ont
jamais dit ordures j'ai jamais dit tu
sais chérie mais vous avez donné la fed
planète parce que c'est pas moi qu'un
site moi je me lève le matin même et
c'est maija se donne pas à voir ça là tu
gêne tout le monde merci mon amour nous
voilà on est juste là pour que ça se
passe bien entre gilles raymond
apparemment je vous le dis parce que
vous n'êtes pas pour habib aussi un
gilles je sais que ça te peine beaucoup
énormément leurs cris j'ai mal dormi de
la nuit je suis extrêmement meurtre et
donc voilà c'est c'est effectivement ces
deux personnes qui ont un rang plus
élevé mais beaucoup voilà je suis très
touchée comme voilà et nous doc gynéco
et moi ça nous peine